have you ever been robbed or had
something you value possibly taken from
you against your will it's violating
feelings of fury of a salt and of
helplessness
that's what corruption feels like
corruption is theft
it is corrosive it is criminal it is
toxic and it is predatory now I'm from
Kenya and in Kenya corruption takes
different forms I want to share the
story of Korea forest with you this is
my hometown of Nairobi
I love Nairobi it's beautiful but it is
a city of paradoxes it is at once
beautiful and challenging but at the
heart of this beautiful city that I call
home is Korea Forest an oasis of green
expansive beauty that would be the envy
of any city anywhere we almost lost
Korea forests to corruption word has
reached my mother
one guy methane that karora forest is
under attack there was a construction
site coming up right in the middle of
the forest government officials had
stolen the forest they had divided sold
and gifted hundreds of parcels of
cholera to their friends and cronies now
in 1977 my mother founded the green belt
movement to plant trees across Kenya
restore green spaces and protect green
spaces much like kora forest
she got together her friends and allies
and together they created what became
one of the most successful tree planting
come
pains in the world it was therefore no
surprise that when word got to her that
Korea was under attack they immediately
sprang into action they battled police
and hired goons to stop the theft of
this forest but fortunately there was an
uprising of support from the clergy
politicians students and the general
public all of whom came out to say no to
corruption and greed and pretty soon
that support was too strong and intense
for the authorities to subdue and Cara
Forrest was saved in the 2000s I joined
my mother the green belt movement and
witnessed the growth of the movements
advocacy activities its expansion beyond
Kenya and an extremely important growing
consensus around the 2004 Nobel Peace
Prize that she received that the
environment democracy and peace were
inextricably linked I also learned that
what my mother had faced that many years
ago trying to protect Cara Forest was
not an isolated incident the corruption
and greed that manifested itself then is
alive and well today from greedy
politicians and public servants willing
to loot public coffers at their expense
corruption is everywhere now corruption
is devastating to any economy democracy
and the environment it robs citizens of
vital social services and renders human
life worthless when young men are
willing to join gangs and brutalize
their communities for a small fee and
women are raped on the way to work and
when they report this the perpetrators
bribe their way out of jail
and when young girls have to sell their
bodies to buy sanitary towels
you know the society is broken in recent
years Kenya has been ranked amongst the
top ten most corrupt countries in the
world even more frustrating for me is
that Kenya loses a third of her national
budget to corruption each year that is
six billion dollars it is totally
unacceptable in a country where
anti-corruption efforts have been
frustrated and ignored and interfered
with we absolutely need new strategies
for dealing with this vice we cannot
complain forever we either decide that
we are going to live with it
or we are going to change it there's
some good news human beings are not born
corrupt at some point these behaviors
are fostered by a culture that promotes
individual gain over collective progress
so if we're going to uproot corruption
we have got to start before it ever
takes root we have got to intervene
early I don't know about your country
but where I come from youth will lead us
into the future
in Kenya today 80% of the population is
under the age of 35 but by their own
admission they have conflicting values
fifty eight percent of young people in
Kenya recently told us they will do
anything to make money an additional
forty five percent said corruption is a
legitimate tool for doing business
seventy-three percent said they would
not be willing to stand up for what they
believe in for fear of retribution
what I learned from my mother
a few years ago was this concept of the
power of one that each of us can be
potent agents of change and that
together we are a force that if we put
our hands together we can change the
situation and no problem is too big
my mother understood this so profoundly
that it was at the center of her work
shifting cultures takes patience
persistence and commitment and it is
extremely slow and deep work but if
we're going to shift a culture we have
got to get that work started and in the
time since her passing we have
established a foundation in her name to
do exactly that but to work with young
people and children to begin to build
character and personal leadership to
inspire a purpose and integrity but
fighting corruption is not as easy as
saying corruption is bad now here are
three strategies that we are employing
that we believe can be replicated in any
school community first we must
understand the why why does corruption
happen in the first place do we call it
for what it is
theft or do we gloss over it with other
words when young children are able to
model what it looks and feels like to
deal with corruption they are likely
when faced with the dilemma in their
future to model what they've been taught
second we need to teach character
explicitly now this may seem obvious but
a child who exhibits a growth mindset
and a sense of self control is
self-confident and a self confident
child is likely to stand
for what they believe third we need to
build personal leadership in our
children early to give them an
opportunity to know what it looks like
to call corruption out when they see it
what it feels like to stand up and be
counted when they're needed and for me
to make the more and most important
connection between human suffering on
one hand and corruption greed and
selfishness on the other we have got to
believe in our capacity to bring about
the future we want to see each of us in
our small way young people must believe
that a new reality is possible
corruption climate change ecosystem
collapse biodiversity loss all these
issues need leadership and in the words
of Babbitt dome of Senegal in the final
analysis we will conserve only what we
love we will love only what we
understand and we will understand only
what we are taught thank you
[Applause]